What does the Bible say about the land
of Israel? I've done series on this and
I'm going to add it to the playlist and
then we're going to tie in with the Holy
Mother because now you're going to see
what or who true Israel is. Let's go
through this systematically.
Here you go. The blessed were words of
our Lord.
The words of our Lord. Right?
You don't like his words? Well, then go
find you another religion. Let's start
with what our Lord says. Let's start
with what our Lord says. Okay.
All right. So, we'll take it
systematically.
Pray for me guys because I got a lot of
demons saying, you know, I'm not like
they'll say, "Oh, you're a troublemaker.
No one wants to plant for you." Matthew
21:33-44.
Listen to another parable. There was a
landowner. This is Jesus who planted a
vineyard and put all put a wall around
it and dug a wine press in it and built
a tower and rented it out to vine
growers went on a journey. And now when
the harvest when the harvest time
approached, he sent his slaves to the
vine growers to receive his fruit. And
the vine growers took his slaves and
beat one and killed another and stoned a
third. Again he went another group of
slaves. He sent another group of slaves
larger than the first. They did the same
thing to them. But afterward he sent his
son to them, saying, "They will respect
my son." Okay, watch. Afterwards, he
sent his son. But when the vine growers
saw the son, they said among themselves,
"This is the heir. Come, let us kill him
and seize his inheritance." And they
took him, threw him out of the vineyard,
and killed him.
Therefore, when the owner of the
vineyard comes, what will he do to those
vine growers? They said to him, he will
bring those wretches to a wretched end,
and will rent out the vineyard to other
vine growers who will pay him the
proceeds at the proper seasons. Did you
hear it?
The parable says, "The Lord's going to
take the kingdom away from Israel, give
it to a nation that will produce the
fruits of the kingdom."
Jesus said to them, "Did you never read
in the scriptures the stone which the
builders rejected
has this has become the chief
cornerstone? This came about from the
Lord and is marvelous in our eyes.
Therefore, I say to you, the king God
will be taken away from you
and given to a nation producing the
fruit of it, and he who falls on the
stone, Jesus, will be broken in piece."
In other words, you'll be humbled and
broken to repentance.
Your pride will be broken. You'll be
brought to your knees in repentance. But
on whomever it falls, it will scatter
them like dust. But if this stone falls
on you, it's going to crush you.
You understand? What was he talking
about? Oh, you know who he's talking
about. But hold on. I want to show you
the parallels in Mark and Luke. Let's
walk through this slowly.
Okay, walk in this slowly.
He had one more, a beloved son. He sent
him last of all to them. Did you hear
it?
Mark 12:16. You understand? Israel's
last chance was who? Jesus. He's saying,
"This is your final chance to get it
right.
This is your last hope.
after this it's over for you saying they
will respect my son but those vine
growers said to another this is the heir
come let us kill him and the inheritance
will be ours and they took him and
killed him and thrown out of the
vineyard now let's go all the way to the
end of it to see what happens
all right so let's walk through this
systematically
right have you not even read the
scripture the stone which
the builders rejected that this has
become the chief cornerstone. This came
about from the Lord and his marvelous in
our eyes. Now, by the way, I used to be
a dispensationalist. I used to bend over
backwards for Israel. I used to kiss
their butt because I thought they were
special. I did because of this theology.
What changed? God opened my eyes.
God opened my eyes.
And they were seeking to seize him. And
yet they feared the crowd for they
understood that he spoke the parable
against them. Against who?
The Jewish crowd.
H And so they left him and went away.
Then they sent some of the Pharisee to
him in order to trap him in a statement
because now they want to get rid of him.
Okay. Now the owner of the vineyard
said, "What shall I do? I will send my
beloved son. Perhaps they will respect
him." This was their final chance.
Right. Last of all, okay, let's walk.
Let's go through it systematically and
I'm going to answer their proof text.
Just be patient. Systematically.
Let's just let's go slowly and then
we're going to get into the Holy Mother.
I promise you. All right. So, watch
here.
All right. You ready?
Matthew 8 5-13.
learn because I'm repeating stuff I've
already covered. I already have a
playlist. I'll add this to the playlist.
I'll add this to two playlists.
Okay. Matthew 5-13. And when Jesus
entered Capernaum Capernum, a centurion,
look, a centurion,
the leader, commander of 100 soldiers,
pleading with him, saying, "Lord, my
servant's lying paralyzed at home,
fearfully tormented." And Jesus said to
him, "I will come and heal him." But the
centurion said,"Lord, I am not good
enough for you to come under my roof.
But just say the word and my servant
will be healed. For I also am a man
under authority with soldiers under me."
And I say to this man, "Go," and he
goes. And to another, "Come," and he
comes. And to my slave, "Do this." And
he does it. Now when Jesus heard this,
he marveled and said to those who are
following, "Truly I say to you, I have
not found such great faith with anyone
in Israel. Did you hear the shot he
took?"
Okay. Did you hear right here?
Do you see what the Lord said? He goes,
"No one in Israel has the faith of this
Roman centurion."
That's a knife in the heart of Netanyah
Netanyahu and all these Christian
Zionist Israeli lovers
to say to Jews that I haven't found
anyone with this kind of faith in
Israel.
A gentile who is a commander of 100
soldiers working for the Roman occupier
is a knife
right in their hearts. Did you catch it?
Do you understand what he just said?
What he just did? He goes, "This Roman
centurion has more faith than all you
Israelites."
And then look, if it still doesn't make
clear to you what he's getting at, and I
say to you that many will come from east
and west, meaning Gentiles, and they
will sit with who? Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob, in the kingdom of heaven. But the
sons of the kingdom, you Israelites, who
are given God's rule, will be cast into
utter darkness in that place where
there'll be weeping and nashing of
teeth. Can it be any clear that Jesus is
perfectly impartial, unbiased,
and he just told the Jews, "You were the
sons of the kingdom. You're given the
kingdom, but now you'll be removed from
it and thrown in hell."
What do you guys don't see? What Bible
are you reading?
What Bible are you reading, man?
And Jesus said to the centurion, "Go, it
shall be done for you as you have
believed." And the servant was healed
that very moment. Now, let me show you
what that kingdom
is now after Christ. Okay, remember
this. Let's go back.
Let's go back. Matthew 21:43.
Therefore, I say to you, the king God
will be taken away from you and given to
a nation producing the fruit of it. Now,
watch who that nation is. Ready? Pay
attention. Watch. The promises of Israel
is now given to the church. Watch. Pay.
I'm going to give you receipts, man.
Watch.
Listen carefully and attentively.
All right.
Okay. Right here.
Tell me who now
has been given the kingdom. Who is God's
holy people? Right. Royal priesthood.
This is what he said to the nation of
Israel in Exodus 195-6.
Okay. Exodus 195-6.
Okay, pay attention.
So now then talking to if notice
conditional if conditional if you will
indeed listen to my voice and keep my
covenant then you shall be my treasured
possession among all the peoples. If he
didn't make it unconditional Christian
Zionists for all the earth is mine you
shall be to me a kingdom of priests and
holy nation. These are the words that
you shall speak to the sons of Israel.
All right. Now notice what the promise
is. If you obey me, you'll be a kingdom
priest, a holy nation. Now watch how God
now took the promises and gave it to the
church.
Peter is speaking to the church that
includes Jews and Gentiles. You also as
living stones are being built up as a
spiritual house for a holy priesthood.
That's the language of Exodus 19.
a kingdom of priests, a holy nation, my
treasured possession. Just applied it to
the church to offer up spiritual
sacrifices acceptable to God through
Jesus Christ. How about here? But you
are a chosen family, a royal priesthood,
a holy nation, a people for God's own
possession. He took every single thing
God said about Israel here, my treasured
possession, kingdom of priest or nation,
and he applied it now to the church.
Does your Bible include the New
Testament Christians, or is it only the
Old Testament?
How about that?
is do you know what happens to people
who end up
overemphasizing
Israel and focusing too much on the Old
Testament? You don't believe me? Go and
Google it or research it. Those Gentiles
who end up putting an unhealthy emphasis
on Israel and the Old Testament
end up in many cases leaving
Christianity altogether and converting
to Judaism.
You know that
not lying. This sick fascination
with Old Testament observance
and Israel has led many Gentiles to
leave Jesus all together.
Did you guys know this?
So notice the very language of Israel
applied to the church. Now, how do you
know it's referring to the church? Here
you go. so that you may proclaim the
excellence of him who has called you out
of darkness into his mar of light. For
you once were not a people. Who do you
think he's talking about at this time?
He's not talking about Israel. He's
talking about the Gentiles. You were not
a people, but now you are the people of
God. You had not received mercy, but now
you have received mercy. Is that in your
New Testament?
Exactly, brother. Noahite laws.
See?
Really? No way.
Still not convinced, huh? All right.
Remember the promises?
Israel, if condition. Do you see the if
here? It's in my Bible. If you obey me,
you'll be my possession, a kingdom,
priest, only nation. What if you disobey
me? I'm going to cut you off. That's
Romans 11. All right. Everything in
balance though. We don't want to be like
these extremists. We want to be
balanced. Not extreme. We want to be
balanced.
And in Lord willing, part two, I'll go
more into this.
Okay. Follow me.
Yeah, it is disgusting that you thought
they were special better than you,
right? It is. Now here again,
Revelation.
And from Jesus Christ, the faithful
witness, the firstborn of the dead, and
the ruler of the kings of the earth, to
him who loves us and released us from
our sins by his blood. And he has made
us to be a kingdom. There's that
language again, priests. Kingdom of
priest who is God and father. To him be
glory and the might forever and ever.
Wait, that sounds like Exodus 19.
See how slow I have to go here? A
kingdom of priests, holy nation. But now
it's applied to the church. And is the
church only ethnically Jewish? All
right.
Revelation 5 8-10.
Why here? And when he had taken the
scroll, the four living creatures, the
24 elders fell down before the lamb.
each one having a harp and golden bowls
full of incense which are the prayers of
the saints. Now watch. And they sang a
new song, saying, "Worthy are you to
take the scroll and to open its seal
because you were slain and purchased for
God with your blood people from every
tribe, not just the tribes of Israel,
every tongue, language, and all nations,
right? All peoples. And these redeemed
by the blood of Christ, they are a
kingdom and a priest to our God and they
reign on the earth. So he just took the
promises of Israel and applied it to the
church which consists of people from all
ethnicities, all languages, not just
Israel.
Is this in your Bible or is it only in
my Bible?